[Musique]
quoi que j'ai arrêté d'avoir de la peine
parce que de la peine j'en ai encore
comme en ce moment mais
[Musique]
justement c'est cette réflexion de me
dire que
la vie continue
pour Karine Blanchette rien n'a plus été
pareil après le 6 juillet 2013 elle
était serveuse au musée café repère
festif pour plusieurs à lac-mégantiques
et épicentre de la tragédie la grande
majorité des 47 victimes il passait la
soirée les autres habitaient tout près
chaque victime avait des amis avait une
famille donc ça en fait du monde qui ont
eu de la peine donc je pense que oui on
a encore besoin de
on a encore besoin des autres ça fait
pas longtemps
ça fait
quelques quelques jours quelques
semaines
avait aussi quitté plus tôt ce soir là
le musée c'était comme chez lui et pas
loin de sa maison
le flash
j'ai un friction sur les bras
dans ta vie on voulait dire
c'est immédiatement retrousser les
manches pour offrir du réconfort avec le
musique café d'été
[Musique]
au travail
me fait craquer un chapiteau ou des
artistes de partout au Québec se sont
relayés avec un peu la gorge serrée mais
le coeur rempli d'amour guérir dans
l'action
oui j'avais ma souffrance mais les gens
autour de moi aussi avaient la leur donc
c'est important pour moi de dire ben
rassemblement tout ça ensemble
puis soyons plus fort ensemble
l'attention médiatique les nombreux
visiteurs ont parfois pesé lourd n'est
pas uniquement plusieurs mégantico à le
disent heureusement ils n'ont pas été
seuls pour affronter la tempête c'est le
Québec en sait qui a passé à nous qui
qui a prié pour nous
parce que je pense que
le fait d'avoir toutes ces pensées là
on est en arrière de vous vous
on vient vous voir on va vous aider à
vous relever
se relever yannick a été l'un des
premiers à reconstruire son resto bar
dans le nouveau centre-ville ils l'a
vendu l'an dernier prêt à tourner une
page importante
de se développer parce que ça va faire
10 ans à peu près la moitié du fait
peut-être
de reconstruction oui c'est triste puis
dans 50 ans ce sera triste encore je me
dis souvent pourquoi c'est arrivé ici et
pas ailleurs probablement parce que on
est une communauté tellement
faire en sorte que ça arrive plus jamais
ailleurs et pour eux l'acnégantique doit
être reconnu pour autre chose que sa
tragédie et c'est moi-même si j'ai une
petite fille pendant la pandémie et tout
ça donc si je me dis ben la vie a
continué super belles choses
[Musique]
partagera à Bénédicte quand elle sera
assez grande mais je veux juste que
comprenne que peu importe quand on vit
des choses comme ça on est toujours
capables de s'en sortir si on sait bien
s'entourer si on est capable d'aller
chercher les outils nécessaires et que
de mettre un genou à terre qu'on vit
quelque chose c'est correct pour juste
trouver la swing pour se lever ici
Marie-Ève Laca Radio-Canada à
Lac-Mégantic